hi i'm jennifer evans cario the
president of sugar spun marketing
adjunct faculty for rutgers university
and the social media faculty chair at
market motive thanks for joining me for
part one in my introduction to social
media marketing series
most people are familiar with social
media when it comes down to the idea of
social media as it relates to business
and marketing there's still a lot of
people in the world that are a little
bit confused in terms of how it really
fits and why it is that it really works
at its most basic level social media is
about people connecting with each other
they're connecting to share thoughts
resources media links deals generalized
conversation it basically takes the
smaller amount of one-to-one
communication we have in our everyday
life and it opens it up to almost an
infinite amount of contact potential
that happens when communication spread
across the globe
social media represents an enormous
market people are turning to the social
web to the point that the social web is
actually becoming the web social media
is no longer just a small part of
marketing social media is one of the
primary ways in which marketing and
communication happens between companies
and individuals
when we talk about who's using social
media there's still a common
misconception within the business world
that it's the younger crowd it's the
younger audience that's coming in but in
the last several years we have seen such
an explosion of the reach of social
media that it's really getting to the
point where there is no single age group
that really dominates social media we
see really really strong numbers spread
across almost all demographics including
that 65 plus demographic that is
flocking to sites like facebook in
droves
now when we look at the amount of time
that's spent on social media we can
quickly begin to see that social media
sites are becoming the primary place
that people invest their time when
they're going online
sites like facebook where a user
averages 423 minutes of time on site per
month
youtube 300 minutes of time on site per
tumblr um a popular micro blogging site
for the people who go there it's 151
minutes per month pinterest users
average about 80 minutes per month and
twitter users average about 25 minutes
per month people are going to these
sites into these services as their
starting point to their interface with
the web and then they're traveling out
into the web to read articles to look at
resources to do their shopping and
that's heavily influenced by the
references the sharing the content that
they're picking up when they're on these
social media sites interacting with
other people that they're connected to